a British nurse has been sentenced to
life in prison for murdering seven
babies in her care Lucy Lippy was found
guilty of attempting to murder six
others at the neonatal Hospital unit
where she worked let me refused to leave
herself for the sentencing the British
prime minister Rishi sunak says that he
wants to change the country's laws to
stop this from happening
I think it's cowardly that people who
commit such horrendous crimes do not
face their victims and hear firsthand
the impact that their crimes have had on
them and their families and loved ones
and we are looking and have been at
changing the law to make sure that that
happens and that's something that will
bring forward in due course
has the latest from London
there have only been three other women
who've been handed down a whole life
order mergers are deemed so dangerous
that the possibility of being released
from prison was deemed too dangerous now
Lucy letby joins their ranks
killing of seven babies at a neonatal
unit in the Countess of Chester Hospital
as well as the attempted killing of six
others now while she did not turn up to
hear her sentencing in court today the
judge addressed the courts and her
directly as if she were there stating
that it was premeditation calculation
and cunning in your actions
now there were also presents some dozen
relatives of the victims as well giving
statements detailing the enormous
distress that these families stop
suffered
also what is being called into question
is why did the hospital leave it so late
for these deaths to be investigated
there was indeed quite a bit of contrast
between how the Consultants were warning
the executives of the hospital of the
issue yet the executives of a hospital
launched two inquiries initially which
failed to include any forensic testing
when eventually police were called in
and investigators were looked at that's
when it became obvious of the extent of
let bees input into this nevertheless
there are serious questions being asked
an inquiry is being put into place but
there are also calls for those
Executives of the hospital to be
compelled to give evidence over why they
left it so late to call the inquiry in
Sonia Gallego Al Jazeera London